[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolf from
tech talk i'm arvin calzicci a content
developer and instructor with the
wolfram u team and today i'll be talking
to our development manager bob san
heinrich who will tell us a bit about
the upcoming paclet repository bob
hi uh thanks servant thanks for the
chance yeah the fact the repository is
uh
new upcoming feature uh product that
we're making here at wolfram to let
people distribute
entire packages of wolfram language
technology
oh so they can distribute you know a a
large group of functions instead of just
one function like in the function
repository yeah that's a typical use
case yeah so it's very common that
you'll have a whole family of
functions or tools or um
code that is interdependent and works
together uh but there it can be more
than functions too so you can have
uh style sheets and palettes and
uh you know external libraries and
service connections and device
connections and basically you can extend
wolfram language environments
in almost any way you can add menu items
and all sorts of stuff and and it's uh
so it's it's a lot bigger in scope what
you can do with a backlit than
a function the function repository which
has to sort of stand alone and work
independently kind of do one thing take
inputs give outputs
and so this this is
a much uh larger
object that we're distributing here oh i
see so style sheets i hadn't thought of
in that context before that kind of
makes sense and you said you can even
add menu items
right yeah yeah you can you can you can
extend front-end uh front-end options
with
with uh paclet and they'll be persistent
and change you know customize your your
environment okay i might have to look
into this myself
yeah yeah you definitely should
definitely should uh some of the things
uh
takes a little bit of uh inside
knowledge or exploring exploring
you know
the deep documentation that you might
find online um to figure out how to do
it but the paclet is is the
best tool
for
for implementing that and especially for
distributing it i see
okay
and i believe that you have uh a bit of
a presentation about these things i do i
do i can go through some of the
information about paclets in the backlit
repository yes
yes let me go ahead and share that
um right so
this is my talk about the peculiar
repository um i'm going to talk a little
bit about what packets are
and
then
we'll talk more about the repository
okay
um so
you know packets like we just said are
extensions and customizations of wolfram
language
the uh very common use probably the most
common use is just a way to
package together a world from language
code functions
symbols objects
right i think i've i think i've seen
some for like uh you know general
relativity calculations or refinement
diagrams and things like that
right yes yes so so a lot of like niche
areas
um that haven't been incorporated into
the wolfram language proper
um people have written written packets
for that are either
that are maybe available somewhere um
which is actually something i talk about
later
but you can do more than just top level
code you can add libraries whether
they're c libraries or
other external libraries you can like i
said earlier do style sheets and pads
and another thing that's great is you
can with your wolfram language code with
the functions that you write you can
create documentation
because just having a raw code file
might be able to accomplish kind of what
you want you can send your code to
someone they can use it but
yeah documentation is
huge it's essential for
distributing code that you know it can
contain documentation so uh paclet also
loves that yeah that's something i you
know definitely use every day with the
standard language and certainly even
with uh function repository functions
it's really useful to have the
documentation available yeah yeah it's a
difference maker for the wolfram
language over uh other other
you know languages out there that just
have better fuller documentation
and usable documentation right so uh how
our pack that's used so
for a long time we've had
what we call the packet manager which is
a set of
functions in the wolfram language for
managing pathways but it hasn't been
documented until pretty recently just a
about a version ago in version 12 is
when some of the
packet management tools cut document
like and so packet object is
kind of a primary thing here it's the
symbolic representation of a backlit so
this one is cloud object it contains all
the code for
interfacing with
cloud from uh from wolfram language
whether you're on desktop or in cloud
itself i see and that and that's loaded
the first time you try and do anything
with clouds yes
cloud related objects yes so people have
been using the code from this backlit
without realizing it right for for
several versions the pack that
exists on the machine and they they do
some cloud operation like cloud deploy
or cloud put right and and it loads this
backlit and
and that's what's going on when you run
a function for the first time maybe and
you see that kind of little blue box pop
up that says it's grabbing updates or
installing
right whatever content right so in
addition to the packets that are stored
in your machine there are packets
available on servers which we'll get to
in a minute as well
and sort of that installation and
updating and caching and loading should
work seamlessly but yeah behind the
scenes and sometimes you see those
somewhat unexpected uh
progress indicators telling you that's
happening right um right so we have a
full
set of tools uh for working with
backlits you know packlit install
uh fine packet fine remote those are
those are sort of some of the main
functions that you'd use if you want to
dive into
what packets you have installed what's
available and you want to kind of
manually manage your own list right
um
right so it usually in most cases
if you want to pack lit
if you know if you find a packet and you
want it and it's not already
installed on your machine
all you really ever need to do is
backlit install
so if you know about pacquiao like say
particle data um right so you can just
install it with backlit install and then
the functions within it
are available
and you can use them right away
this one is pulling in data from some
server about particles and then if you
if you like the backlit and you want to
use it you just keep using it forever
you never did you do anything again if
you've experimented with it and it's not
what you want you need or you need to
save hard drive space or something you
can you can always uninstall it with
backlit install and and i assume that
it's coincidental that the name of the
packlet and the name of the function
that's being used from the paclet here
are identical
yes that's uh
yes that's coincidental i mean it's not
rare
uh but
yeah that's not necessary okay i'm sure
that particle data also has other
functions not in particle data
all right um
so right so where do paclets come from
um so primarily historically packets
have come from
the wolfram backlit server uh which is
packletserver.wolfr.com
not a url because there's no reason to
visit it in a browser well there's not a
link because there's no reason to visit
it in a browser
um
it's just uh a server that
stores packets and has a has an index
that wolfman language knows how to use
and the wolfman which can go there and
see what packets are available what
versions are if there's updates all
these
all the things it all happens behind the
scenes um
so you know you can see for instance
what service connections
are available
um as paclets
on the wolfram packet server by using
that url as the location oh so you
mentioned that service connections could
be part of paclets but even the built-in
service connections are built on this
backlit functionality that's right
that's right most of them are i think
there's a few of the very early ones
[Music]
are
not um as happens yeah yeah yeah
um and then so that's you know 99 of all
packets that anyone has ever used
have either
been included in the installation of
mathematica or
they've been downloaded from from this
path of server uh there are few other
packet sites in the world that people
have sort of reverse engineered ours
figured out how to make them
uh this is one i don't mind
but don't mind showing it here it's this
has nothing to do
with
wolfram research but other people have
figured out how to make backlit sites um
but we love our dedicated users exactly
um
you know also you know when you can use
the
packlit tools like we just looked at
that guide page with practifine and pack
and phone remote there's one there
called pack paclet that just takes your
your packet and creates a dot packet
file which is
something like a zip file
and so you can do that and you can you
know email it around you can post it on
your website and people are free to grab
it and install it
i wouldn't recommend it uh if unless you
really trust the source and you know
that it's a good it's a good packet um
but yeah there there have been other
ways
for people to
share things so
uh so yeah so this sort of explains why
we need a backlit repository because
if you had a great set of tools in
norfolk language and you wanted to share
it with the world
you didn't have very many good options
you could either get a job at wolfram
and tell us ask us to put it on the
faculty server uh you could create your
own packet site like the one we looked
at a minute ago but that's hard you got
to figure out how to do it and there's
no documentation and yeah yeah or you
can just yeah release a dot packet file
on
on a message board somewhere and hope
people trust you these are some quite
limited options yes none of these are
good none of these are good i made
getting a job wilfred worked out for me
but uh but it yeah you might
you might have life restrictions um
so so yeah there's not been a good
answer so that's why we need a willful
text repository um
so
uh yeah what is the wolfenbecker
repository it's a place to find and
share documentable language backlits
uh and it'll work just like the world
from backlit server that has existed for
decades
uh it's part of the resource system
so if anybody's familiar with the
function repository the data repository
the neural net repository
uh it's it's another repository in the
resource system a paclet repository um
and the each of these has its own unique
set of content
in this case it's it's a paclet uh but
what's different about this one
uh
is that anybody can publish packers
which we'll
talk more about on the next slide
um
so
right so features each backlit has a
website with documentation so when you
publish your pack layout in the backlit
repository it makes a website all
your documentation all of your notebook
documentation is hosted on the web so
people can browse it before they install
it
see what it's see what your packet's
about and what it can do
all the documented functions
in your packet
can be used
by other users without permanent
installation so we talked about how
packlit install is great because you use
it once so you never have to use it
again but it's kind of a commitment
right so
uh if you
if the packlet isn't something that's
made by wolfram and tested by our qa
team and gone through a release process
and
from some guy who
maybe has a couple phds and so you think
you might have some good stuff
but you're not sure maybe it's also
you know
too heavyweight or slow or something and
you just sort of want to you sort of
want to give it a trial run
we have uh
you can from the website that's just
like a click to copy button where you
can grab a piece of code and run it
right away
okay temporarily yeah you can grab some
of the definitions out from the from the
packet without committing to installing
right it'll download it and sort of run
it in a in like a temporary location and
okay in your next kernel session it
won't be there unless nice take the next
step
to uh
to install it
uh and packets are published under a
publisher id
um so unlike the other repositories
where everything kind of lives in a
global namespace
um you know the function
uh birds say is just named bird say in
the functional repository it's not named
it's not named rick
bird say because rick made it but in the
paclid repository if he made a paclet
called you know you know bird talk and
more it would be called rick bird
talking more
because uh
yeah
these are self-published and there's not
that step of
review and curation
and you know consistency
um so basically
publishers
are which
could be thought of as developers are uh
you know given the power to publish your
own work and so in order to make that
work
everything needs to be prefixed with
this publisher id right so that's true
for the paclet names and symbol contexts
i can see and is that true as well for
all of the actual wolfram language
symbols that might be associated with
that backlit or are those free to just
have kind of standard names uh
yeah that is true for those two um okay
by by convention at the very least um we
want
we want
the symbols that are exported from these
backlits to live in your publisher id
context okay
um
right and then a big feature that we
have is the definition of book so if
you've submitted anything to the
function repository you've used or the
data repository you've used a definition
notebook
that lets you compile all the info all
the metadata and the content and sort of
validate it and test it before you
submit it
and we're going to have
a similar
definition notebook for paclets
here um
right so one thing a common question
might be what are the differences
between pacman function repository
uh we talked about this right at the
beginning packets are bigger and more
complex
um and then what we just talked about
packet repository does not have
reviewers right you push the button on
your notebook
uh it takes a little bit of chugging on
the server but in you know five minutes
it's live and there was there were no
humans employed by wolfram research that
had to approve it um
and then there's this namespace thing
that we talked about where you have a
publisher id okay so so this is a really
quick way to get out you know a lot of
functionality to people who are who
might be interested in using it
yes
yes that's true
yes
uh right so then uh can i see a demo yes
the answer is yes
um so this is
you can try to go to this url yourself
but most people you're gonna get an
unauthorized
error at the moment
but it's coming soon
um so this is a preview
never before
seen publicly so this probably looks
something like the function repository
uh to most people if they're familiar
with it
we have these in categories that it's
probably it's a fluid category situation
where right now we're using the same
categories
that you see on reference.welcome.com
uh but that might not be right we might
adjust these um so if we look at
sort of some of the some of the examples
that are here now um you can see each
packet is here and you can see this
publisher prefix well here i'll just go
back to that page so you can see each
one has this publisher prefix so bob
that's one that i made and then well us
as a company we're publishing some
content through the
through the paclet repository so we have
a wolfram which you know it's probably a
good one to trust
uh
our my colleague connor has his own
publisher id where he's published some
of his own work
uh so if we look at one of these you can
see we have like this landing page
where it kind of tells you
a description of it
you can go into sort of a more detailed
bulleted list tables
there's a
main guide page where it kind of lists
all the functions all the symbols
and then examples
and so what i said earlier about you can
immediately test these out if i take
this
and i go back and i make
a new notebook which is coming in a full
screen
all right
you can run it and
do you want to increase the
magnification there as well
sure that's a great idea
right so you can run it you can run it
here and it'll work immediately
so this you know the developer of this
speculator might have some
minor bug
um
to consider but uh you can see it works
right away but it's not persistently
installed forever
um so anybody can kind of use this stuff
right and that's that's very cool that
uh that specific example because of
course if you're using two different um
random functions it's checking for
equivalence between them so if you
evaluated them you would get different
random numbers but there it's just
checking for the code equivalents and
that got true so right yeah this is a
neat feature we've had sort of behind
the scenes on some of our uh projects
for a while that we're gonna expose
through peculiar repository looking
forward to that yeah um
right so um how do you publish your
paclit impact repository you know in in
in the coming weeks when it becomes
available at least as a as a beta
well you need to have version 13
which is also not released but will be
available as a beta
you need to have a publisher id which
anybody can get um
you can just you can get it through the
function or data repository right now
it's the same publisher id so you can if
you can publish to those if you can
submit to those then you'll be able to
publish the packet repository and then
you need a packet and
how to develop a pack that is way beyond
the scope of this chat right now
um that that's but there is a lot more
documentation and workflows and tools to
help you create packets coming out with
this in version 13.
um
so so yeah you'll end up with something
a directory layout that uh
you know looks something like this with
you
typically you have like a kernel
directory and a documentation directory
and you have a paclet info file
and yeah so you
packets are developed as directories um
and then
you can
create a definition notebook which i've
talked about a few times you
just you browse you go to
uh
that directory where you have your
packet
say okay
and
it generates one of these guys
that so this might look familiar to
people
of you who have developed function
resources but this is for packlets
and you know has sort of a file browser
and you can add metadata you can give it
all the stuff that we saw on the website
examples
you can tell it what categories it
should be in you can
you know tell it where your packet will
work is an important feature some
packets might
not work on windows or so on and so
forth um
and then and then you can build the
packet you can check it with all sorts
of validation tools that will mark it up
if there's issues
and uh you'll be able to deploy it to
your cloud account which is completely
different than publishing the repository
that's
uh absolutely no control we won't even
have a way to take it down if we wanted
to no matter what you put up there and
then you can publish it in the
repository right i was just about to ask
about the cloud deployment based on that
option at the bottom that you know
specify does this work locally does this
work on the cloud so if you have some
paclet via the paklet repository and
you're in a cloud notebook can you just
uh
install that
via a cloud notebook or do you need to
deploy it first and then you can use it
in the cloud notebook
um
if it's from the repository you should
just be able to use it in a cloud
notebook um yes if yeah as long as the
packlet itself works in cloud that
that temporary use case where you can
use it without installing it
might not initially work on in within
cloud but okay the installation will so
we'll see we'll see that's something
that's
currently being
uh
investigated and developed
uh right so that uh that's my talk
okay well thank you so much bob for
telling us a bit about the paclet
repository there i'm really looking
forward to the release of this
functionality i think it'll be quite
useful for a lot of people
smi thanks for having me it's great yeah
of course talk to you later bye-bye bye
so that was bob san heinrich who told us
about the upcoming paclet repository
functionality in the wolfram language
stay tuned for more tech talks where
we'll be covering everything from covent
analysis to cryptography
to blockchain and a special note
regarding wolfram u content development
the example that bob showed there about
code equivalents will be very useful to
folks who are looking to design courses
so look forward in particular for us
we'll from you people to the release of
that functionality thanks we'll see you
in the next tech talk
[Music]